big smiles and more than happy to be
back in the public eye traveling by car
a relaxed and laughing queen chatted to
officials as she arrived at the royal
windsor horse show moments like this are
becoming rare for the 96 year old
monarch so this surprise appearance
delighted show spectators
well i'm very pleased to have been able
to see her it really makes a difference
and
being able to come to windsor and
actually see her on in her back garden
she felt in any way well she'd be here
and uh hurrah because she was here so
that's a sign
that the queen's okay she's sliding
under the radar you know have a look you
have a look at the horses and things
that's one of her favorite you know one
of her hobbies her
passions so i think that's amazing
using a walking stick we're now more
used to seeing her with her majesty sat
in the royal box beside the wessex's to
watch her pony balmoral leah take first
prize in one of the competitions
even after all these years even the
queen still loves winning rosettes and
gold cups
giddy with excitement talk of ill health
seemed forgotten
the two-hour visit was the first time
the monarch had been seen in public
since the duke of edinburgh's memorial
service in march
ongoing episodic mobility problems meant
she's reluctantly had to miss various
in-person engagements including the
state opening of parliament earlier this
week
we've been told to be flexible with our
expectations when it comes to seeing her
majesty but there was so much
anticipation for her to be here we know
that she's been coming to this show ever
since she was very young it's one of her
favorites and epitomizes her absolute
adoration
[Music]
the jubilee show of equestrian sport
continues on the grounds of windsor
castle over the weekend on sunday ten of
the queen's great-grandchildren will
play a part in the finale
thoughts turn to whether she'll be there
or want to watch more of her winning
ponies whilst not an official engagement
today's visit is a reassuring sign her
majesty intends to take part in as many
of her jubilee events as possible
her appearances may increasingly be more
of a last-minute surprise astronomer
inactive sky news in windsor